foreign
[Music]
tightly contested presidential election
will go to a runoff later this month the
incumbent president Richard has a
five-point lead of his main opposition
Challenger Kamal kilishtarulu in the
first round let's get straight to my
colleague Sami zaidan who's in Istanbul
Sammy
thank you so much Adrian yes it was a
night it was a knife edge and a nail
biting first round of voting and vote
counting and it's Ended as you said
is in the lead but no candidate has a
clear majority and that puts the
opposition candidate in a particularly
tough position now because he's behind
well we heard from the opposition as
they call them party or republican
People's Party they're vowing to fight
on but they're saying they will accept
that this is going to a second round no
dispute there but it's an uphill task
one of the reasons why the candidate who
came in third place for the presidential
race in and on it's not clear if he will
find kalish darolu's positions on things
like the Kurdish file on things like the
fatala gulen file to be right-wing
enough to win over his endorsement and
the support of sin and Owen's followers
and synonym has been talking about his
condition for an endorsement saying hey
you better distance yourself from what
he considers to be terrorists you better
commit yourself to expelling Syrian
refugees from this country or don't come
and talk to me about an endorsement
well I looked back on an intense night
of vote counting in which no one
candidate emerged with a majority but
two candidates emerged vowing they will
get one
[Music]
Turkish president
addressing supporters outside the
headquarters of the justice and
development party in Ankara it was his
first appearance since the polls closed
he told them he's ready for a runoff
seeing that the margin with the closest
opponent is more than 2 million votes
and with the final result we will see a
wider margin if our nation has decided
to go to a second round we will respect
that decision
leads a six-party opposition Alliance
that's determined to unseat erdogan he
urged his supporters to be patient
despite his smear campaign against us
erdogan hasn't gotten the result he
wanted if the first round wasn't enough
to receive the Mandate we are going to
get it in the runoff election election
officials have been counting the votes
throughout the night third presidential
candidate sinan owan has done better
than expected analysts say he has the
potential to be king maker Juan is an
anti-immigrant anti-uh Refugee candidate
and I think it's basically a new Epoch
in Turkish politics because both sides
will Court him to get his votes and they
will have to do at least something to
satisfy his base and his message
so far owan is refusing to back either
urduan or kilish
there will be another difficult 15 days
ahead of us and during this time if the
elections are completed with the current
results and go to the second round we
will do our best to make this process a
good one for our nation and our country
at this time we are not saying that we
will support one party or the other
erdogan has led turkey for two decades
overseeing growth in trade and foreign
investment as well as ambitious
infrastructure development projects but
more recently he's been criticized for
high inflation and the Turkish lira's
devaluation to the U.S dollar
[Applause]
says he wants to reform the system of
governance and return power to
Parliament a runoff vote will now be
needed to decide turkey's future Sami
zaidan Al Jazeera Istanbul
all right we can now go to the arc party
headquarters in Ankara we have rasul
Sardar standing by live for us we can
find out what the vibe is like there it
was a very bitter divisive and
polarizing fight for the first round
what an arc party officials signaling in
terms of how they're going to fight the
second round rasul
well Sammy right now at the building in
the building right behind me which is up
party's headquarter president erdogan is
still in a meeting with his a team they
have seen the ministers members of the
cabinets arriving one after one and over
another and now it has been almost hours
that the meeting is still here and
underway so probably this is what we are
hearing from people that are getting
news from inside saying that they are
working on a strategy for the second
round however just yesterday at night
after late in the night once the the
picture regarding the election results
were almost getting clearer so he has
came to Ankara and president erdogan
delivered a speech to his supporters
that were waiting for him thousands of
supporters and then during his speech he
has already signaled how his strategy is
going to shape so he was focusing on
terrorism fighting on terrorism and
focusing a on a on the advancement that
the country has gone through in the last
two decades and also promising a more
powerful turkey a more assertive turkey
in the international Arena so when you
look at this narrative you will see that
it is matching actually the national the
the expectation of the nationalists and
conservative base of this country so one
thing that we have seen uh from the last
yesterday's election is that the
nationalism and conservatism are on Rise
and that's why erdogan probably is going
to build that strategy build up on this
and probably he's going to more and more
address these two segments of the
society another nationalists and the and
the the conservatives so that's why he
was focusing on the unity on being
powerful on the continuity and stability
of the country it seems that for the
next two weeks we are going to hear a
lot of such similar stuff from president
erdogan and his campaign team
I'm glad you mentioned that Russell
because related to that we're going to
talk about the opposition does it look
like the path ahead for kalistarolu is
narrow at this point
that's correct as the results are being
regarded as a success from the uh from
AG party the ruling Arc party and
president erdogan on the other hand for
the opposition actually it's a huge blow
because many of the polls were showing
that the leader of the opposition is
leaving however the results have shown
the opposite and now there is a real
deep disappointment in within the
opposition so let's keep in mind that
this is a coalition six parties
different backgrounds ideological
backgrounds different stand and also
different approach to many stuff they
had only one common goal bringing
erdogan down Printing and end to
everyone's error and now as the figures
do not show that they are going to win
as of now there's a huge disappointment
here so that's why at first stage we are
being told that the opposition needs to
make a damage control and then they are
going to develop their strategies and so
far there hasn't been that much of the
public appearances from the from the
opposition they have seen just one video
from
and saying that he's not going to give
up and he's here and he's going to fight
till the end however as I said it's a
fragile Coalition and probably we'll see
that President also is going to play on
that fragility of the opposition so the
biggest test for the opposition now is
how to keep together until May 28 which
is going to be the day of the second
round for the presidential election
absolutely thanks so much they're
reporting us live from Ankara and as
rasul mentioned the Big Challenge ahead
of the opposition was how to end
erdogan's rule looks far the result so
far looks far from that kind of scenario
type erdogan leading although he didn't
get an outright majority still faces a
challenge to his rule but he is leading
and let's face it the ruling Coalition
as well when it comes to parliamentary
elections the latest projections show
them to be also leading there with 49 of
the vote and having a majority of seats
already in the parliament according to
the first round results technically fun
fact that boat counting is still going
on because there's
0.1 percent of the vote uncounted but
unlikely to change these projections
when that 0.1 percent comes in we'll
continue to monitor this but for now I'm
going to hand you back to delha
reporting live from Istanbul many thanks
Sammy